why do electrons in an atom keep a
distance from the protons if obviously
charges attract
why don't electrons crash into the
nucleus excellent question
yeah it's an excellent question and
there is no answer to that in other
words under quantum they have no answer
to that in fact it gets even worse it
gets very much worse if you look at the
P orbitals
what's an orbital an orbital is the
region where you can find an electron
bead the P orbitals go through the
center of the atom out the other side
because and the way they get around that
is saying well the p orbital really
doesn't go through the center of the
atom it kind of starts on the outside of
the proton so you'll see this elongated
balloons and that's what they are
balloons and if you can find the
electron anywhere in here but you can't
find in the center of the atom where the
proton is and you say well why can't you
find in the center if this guy's
negative any other guys positive as soon
as it reaches anywhere close to the
proton the protons just suck it in it's
more or less the same problem that we
have with black holes and I'm not by
digressing here I'm just giving you an
analogy what is what is this white hole
or what is the stuff that comes out of
black hole which makes it have
visibility well according to these folks
Hawking explained now in the Hawking
radiation half of the particle falls
into the black hole the other half comes
out you know they kind of split you have
the negative and the positive that one
goes into the hole the other one escapes
because now it's been freed from its
shackles but the question is whether
both particles fall in if you got this
immense gravity it's that like gravity
stops at the event horizon
you've got gravity if there's a black
hole the event horizon is just the the
line of danger that's where you get
sucked in but one centimetre right
outside that it doesn't mean that
there's no grass
there's still a lot of remedy there in
fact there has to be gravity if the
black hole is sucking material from a
star which is you know light-years away
as they say right so if it's sucking
from over there obviously anything in
the vicinity of the black hole should
fall in there should be no Hawking
radiation under what circumstance would
the split particle the the twin that got
you know split from the other guy one
falls in fine we understand that why did
the other guy come to your eye and
that's what we can't explain the
electron and the atom is is more or less
the same thing has the same concept that
the mathematicians you have given this
they're saying here you have an atom and
and here you have the electron be going
all around it but it used to be the
planetary model that was born they said
what a bore was wrong
so they came up with Schrodinger's
equation which essentially says you can
find the electron anywhere here but he
came with a probability wave whatever
that thing is okay so you find the
electron beat all around and and around
the nucleus and the question is if it's
jumping around and gets close to the
proton why does it fall in the same
thing as the black hole you know why
doesn't why does it why can you do
ionization ionization is the removal of
the electron bead from them from the
let's use hydrogen that since it's only
got one
if you ionize hydrogen you remove the
electron bead and the question is how
did you do that how did you pull the
electron bead if it's a discrete entity
how did you keep it within hydrogen to
begin with these are the questions as
you'll never have an answer to and
that's why they say no one understands
quantum mechanics that's the best answer
I can give you